Die maya hochkultur war im ersten jahrtausend nach christus wohl weiter entwickelt als die meisten anderen zivilisationen dieser zeit doch plötzlich
verschwand sie scheinbar bis heute liegen noch immer viele aspekte dieser mysteriösen kultur im dunkeln wie
beispielsweise eben auch die ursachen für ihren untergang und das rätsel ist immer noch nicht gelöst warum genau
setzte ab dem achten jahrhundert nach christus ein derart rasanten niedergang ein jetzt hat ein forschungsteam aus cambridge vielleicht die antwort darauf gefunden
alle wichtigen infos jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ihr untergang kam plötzlich und bis heute ist das rätsel um das ende der maya hochkultur nicht gelüftet und das obwohl viele schriftzeichen
entschlüsselt werden konnten fest steht der dschungel hat am ende die verlassenen städte in windeseile
überwuchert bisher wurden drei faktoren und auch deren kombination als ursache in erwägung gezogen krieg
raubbau und dürre schon frühere untersuchungen wiesen auf eine
außergewöhnliche dürreperiode zu dieser zeit hin boden ablagerungen hätten gezeigt dass es in dem meyer gebiet um
900 nach christus eine trockenheit gegeben haben soll um diese theorie näher zu kommen hat jetzt ein britisches forschungsteam
ablagerung aus einem see in der nähe der stadt medina untersucht konkret ging es um eine abgeschlossene lagune auf der süd
mexikanischen halbinsel
yucatan hier konnten sich die meier wohl ein wenig länger halten als im südlichen tiefland das von urwald durchzogen ist das forschungsteam
analysiert in verschiedene ablagerungen und konnte so rückschlüsse
auf die vorherrschenden umweltbedingungen ziehen die erklärung dafür bei extremer trockenheit
verdunsten leichte partikel und die schweren bleiben zurück dabei können dann gibt's kristalle entstehen in denen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler tatsächlich
ein geschlossenes
uraltes wasser fanden dieses
untersuchten sie auf verschiedene isotope von wasser und sauerstoff
denn bei trockenheit verdunsten logischerweise zunächst die leichteren isotope höhere anteile von schweren isotopen
dagegen lassen auf eine dürrephase rückschließen um zu vergleichen bediente sich das forschungsteam an ablagerungen aus der jahren
1994 bis 2010 denn in diesem zeitraum waren niederschläge und temperatur genau ermittelt worden
die analyse der damit aufgestellten thema modelle zeigte ein überraschendes ergebnis
der aktuellen analyse zufolge kann man davon ausgehen dass die jährliche niederschlagsmenge
damals teilweise um achtung bis zu
70 prozent unter den heutigen werten gelegen haben muss dazu schreiben sie in ihrer studie
wir fanden hohe wahrscheinlichkeit für einen trockenheit insbesondere am anfang etwa
750 bis 850 nach christus und am ende etwa
950.000 50 nach christus der späten klassischen phase
diese daten sollen jetzt genutzt werden um konkret herauszufinden wie dadurch die damalige landwirtschaft der maya kultur in mitleidenschaft
gezogen wurde selbst wenn zudem weiterer faktoren wie beispielsweise krieg beim kollaps der hochkultur eine rolle gespielt haben sollten zeigt dieses ergebnis
deutlich welche fatalen folgen klimatische veränderungen für das leben auf der erde haben können und tatsächlich
könnte es auch ein indiz dafür sein wie unsere aktuelle zivilisation untergehen könnte durch den
menschengemachten
klimawandel er ist für uns tatsächlich
existenzbedrohend wenn ihr kein video verpassen wollt auch extra videos und livestreams nicht dann werdet mitglied hier auf dem kanal
und nehmt auch noch ein paar privilegien mit außerdem unterstützen sie uns mit einem kleinen betrag einfach auf mitglied werden die klicken
direkt hier unter dem video und vielen vielen vielen dank an alle die schon mitglied geworden sind das macht uns etwas
unabhängiger von schwankenden werbeeinnahmen hier auf youtube ja dann das kennt er schon werden noch nicht drauf gekriegt hat auf jeden fall hier
uns auf whatsapp folgen da werdet ihr nämlich immer aktuell informiert wenn ein neues video online geht auf jeden fall auch unseren schwesterkanal
abonnieren klicks um social media das geht hier und natürlich nicht die glocke vergessen ich mach's nochmal
genau die und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken die mythen der sumerer mysteriös und
rätselhaft bis dann
bleibt dran